what is going on inside the head of
Saddam Hussein next on book TV dr.
Gerald post the founding director of the
CIA Center for personality and clinical
behavior offers his assessment of the
Iraqi leader has outlined in his new
book this program runs an hour
dr. post is currently a professor of
George Washington University's professor
of psychiatry political psychology and
international affairs not only do I need
notes but obviously it's a mouthful
prior to his becoming in professor at GW
he worked for the CIA and he is the
founder of a the program they are called
director of political psychology and he
thought it would be important to mention
that among his vast experience he was
the person who was involved at Camp
David in the psychological profiles of
Bagan in Sadat during the Carter White
House and the other important thing to
mention is the dr. post is the director
of the Center for the analysis of
personality and political behavior now
I'm not even sure what all those things
mean but I'm pleased to introduce dr.
Gerald post and he will help us
understand what the psychological
assessment of political leaders is all
about but I'd like to thank first very
much politics and prose for hosting this
and to congratulate politics and prose
for their exquisite sense of timing
which was really really a quite
remarkable what I thought I would do
given the cascading sequence of what I
thought I would do given the sequence of
events that has occurred is to try in a
half an hour to
summarized the major thrust of the
profile that I presented to Congress
initially during the first Gulf crisis
in 1990 in it and have since gone
through a major updating and to focus in
particular and I think on the questions
that I'm sure of most concern to you
what does this understanding of him mean
in terms of how this coming conflict is
likely a play out will he go into exile
why has he held on so assiduously to
weapons of mass destruction during this
period of time what will happen when
he's pushed to the to the wall so with
that brief scope note let me have first
observed that in the several hundred
profiles I've done over my career first
the CIA and now George Washington this
man has the very most disturbed
background of any leader I have ever
assess and let me summarize that very
briefly for you during it it goes back
to the womb indeed during his mother's
pregnancy with him first his father died
of cancer and then a 12 year old brother
died in the eighth month of that same
pregnancy the mother understandably was
severely depressed by this and both
tried to commit suicide and to abort
herself of the pregnancy when Saddam was
born and all of you who are parents will
recognize with what this means she
turned away from her newborn child would
not accept him in her arms and
unfortunately her brother Khairallah
rescued Saddam at this time for the
first time and for the first three years
of life was he and his family who who
served as surrogate parents until the
mother remarried and then Saddam went
back to greet his his mother and and his
new stepfather and the new stepfather
proceeded to rather savagely physically
and psychologically abused young Saddam
now this in psychological terms would
give one what would generally be called
the wound itself and the kind of
deep-seated wounds that really one can
never recover from and most people with
this kind of background would be left
hesitant weak dependent indecisive
having no doubts prey upon them but at
age nine Saddam's uncle came to the
rescue once again when Saddam once in an
education as parents refused and from
age 9 on Saddam was raised by his uncle
Khairallah who filled him with tales of
his heroic relatives who had fought for
Araki nationalism told him someday he
would follow in the path of
Nebuchadnezzar and Saladin who liberated
Jerusalem for the Muslims from the
Crusaders and 1187 and then when he went
for high school to Baghdad the the
streets were aflame with the passions of
Arab nationalism for Nasser had just
taken over the reins of Iraq I'm sorry
of Egypt in his coup and he hopes
someday to inherit the mantle of
leadership of the radical Arab world so
this were these were the beginnings of
his his life and it was his success came
as a consequence of violence he was
rewarded for that but let me let me leap
ahead to to note that he had these
dreams of glory dreams of glory sitting
astride this this that's really quite
shaky psychological foundation and for
all these years he aspired to be
recognized as one of the world's great
leaders especially to be recognized as a
great socialist leader believed he
belonged in the in to be ranked with
Castro of Cuba Tito of Yugoslavia Ho Chi
Minh Mao Zedong but the world didn't so
recognize him until 1990 and I think
this is
terribly important to understand the
impact of the first Gulf crisis we in
the West thought of this as a decisive
triumph for the West this was a decisive
triumph for Saddam Hussein because now
finally he was recognized as that world
class world leader he gave a guttural
grunt oil barrel prices jumped $20 a
barrel that thou Jones plunged 200
points he had the world by the throat
more importantly Palestinians took him
on as their new hero as did the radical
Arab world they were cheering for him
from the rooftops in Jordan and their
camps and in Gaza and the occupied
territories fulfilling the prophecy of
his uncle so this was an important
important triumph for him now in terms
of what happened in 1991 as you may have
heard in the Dan Rather
interview this was not a defeat in the
war it was a battle which they lost to
be sure but actually on the third day of
that conflict Saddam held a press
conference in which he declared victory
and this press was rather astounded and
he explained well it was widely assumed
that we would only be able to hold out
against this mightiest air attack ever
mounted for two days
we've already held out for three days
and for each further day we hold out it
only magnifies further the scope of our
victory now with that overview bringing
us up to 1991 I'd like to just note a
couple of a couple of other points for a
four-year interest he's been widely
characterized as the the madman of the
Middle East nothing could be further
from the truth this man is a rational
calculator
having said that he often miscalculates
for two reasons one of which has changed
since then since 1991 the first reason
the one that has changed is he was
really very ethnocentric at that at the
time of the first Gulf crisis intended
to look at the world through
middle-eastern glasses perhaps did not
really understand
the matter the degree of resolve in the
in the US position though if we were
bluffing in the same way that Middle
Eastern leaders typically do but more
importantly he is surrounded by
sycophants who for very good reason are
afraid to tell him what he needs to hear
and instead tell him what he wants to
hear and let me give you two rather
chilling examples in 1979 when he first
stepped out from behind the scenes he
had really been running Iraq as number
two since they took over in the coup but
in 1979 he finally assumed fully the
reins of power and there were 21 in his
among his senior officials he didn't
fully trust he captured one of these or
had him one are these arrested and his
family and instructed him as to the plot
that he would confess publicly no such
plot but he told him what he would
confess to and if he didn't his family
would be a tortured and executed then
and this has been captured on video
while he is sitting off to the side of
the of this large hall just imagine
yourself in this hall you're my 200
senior officials and he is going through
the this man this confessor the name of
every single person in the hall halide
was he a conspirator no Mahmoud was he a
conspirator yes
at that point two security goons come
and take mark mood and bring him to the
back everyone is totally paralyzed with
fear everyone knows as their colleagues
and friends are being seized that
there's no such plot are they going to
be named next when all 21 have been
taken out of the hall having smiled and
smoked his cigar during this whole
procedure a Saddam at this point
congratulate s' the rest for their
outstanding loyalty to him and as a
reward indicates they will have the
honor of forming the firing squads for
their comrades the the the
next morning at dawn that's the first
episode the second episode is even more
chilling in some ways I might note that
all of the remaining 178 or so were
quite taken by the need to never even
vaguely think about making a disloyal
comment about about Saddam in 1982 in
the war with Iran which Saddam had
started in in 1980 it was going quite
badly he needed a cease fire missiles
are raining on Baghdad and Saddam had
made a proffer of a ceasefire to the
Iraq through the Iranian government but
by now home a knee was obsessed with us
with this Saddam said there'd be no
peace with Iraq until he was no longer
president
so Saddam called a cabinet meeting his
executive cabinet and so gentlemen we
have a dilemma we need to have peace we
need to have a ceasefire but how meny
says there'll be no peace until I'm no
longer your president what say you and
of course to a man and everyone says
Saddam is a raka raka Saddam of course
you must continue as our president and
he that says no no I want your frank
candid and creative suggestions and his
oxford-educated Minister of Health dr.
Ibrahim took him quite seriously and
said well Saddam you might want to think
of temporarily stepping down as
president until our goal of peace was
achieved and then when that has occurred
resuming the presidency fairly shrewd
suggestion I think as the story goes
Saddam thanked him gravely for his
candor and had him arrested on the spa
the minister's wife went to Saddam that
evening and said please your excellency
my husband has always been loyal to you
please return my husband to me and he
was apparently deeply touched by the
sincerity of her request and promised
her he would return a husband to her and
he kept that promise as best as I can
tell the only promise he's ever kept and
returned a husband to her the next day
and a black canvas body bag
disarticulated into pieces this
powerfully concentrated the attention of
the other ministers who to a man said
you must stay on as president the war
went on for another bloody six years now
there's a another version of that story
a somewhat milder which is that a Saddam
thanked him for his candor invited him
out into the corridor and then with a
scene out of the Godfather that was
reported not only to be his favorite
movie but his training manual put a
bullet through his brain now which of
these stories is true or whether either
of these stories is true is immaterial
they are believed to be true and for his
ministers that means they are under
great peril to say to him what they
believe he wants to hear rather than
ever constructively criticizing him and
this this is very very important to
understand so he can makes he can be one
can be if you gave him psychological
tests totally in touch with
psychological reality and totally out of
touch with political reality if your if
your leadership circle is is so sick of
venting now there have been a number of
changes since 1990 and 91 which are
important to document but first me let
me first characterize his personality
for you just to give you a handle on
this
well I've noted he's by no means a
madman and is quite rational he does
carry conceptually the the most
dangerous personality disorder as his
way of thinking of him which is
malignant narcissism it's kind of a
juicy phrase I was once doing a film for
WGBH or the frontline show during during
1990 and I used that hiding Carter stop
the interviewing burst out laughing and
said I can think of at least five
Network anchors who that that tie that
tied with it
the four components of malignant
narcissism are a such extreme
grandiosity such a messianic sense of
self that there's no real capacity to
empathize with the pain or suffering of
other people including his own people be
paranoid not paranoid crazy but ready to
be betrayed ready ready to lash out
ready to be attacked course you don't
have to be paranoid now to believe we're
out to get him but he's extremely alert
to danger see he really has no evidence
of a conscience whatsoever we can
justify any kind of change as as being
revolutionary pragmatism and fourthly
and quite importantly he'll use whatever
aggression is necessary to accomplish
his goals without a qualm of conscience
so he would rather have ten innocent
members of his government killed while
getting all of the potential plotters
then to then to let one potential
plotter go sort of the opposite of the
American concept of justice so this is a
very dangerous personality he he has
indeed and it's important to note that
is part of the difficulty he has hearing
wise counsel he's so caught up in his
own magnificence and anyone who's been
to Baghdad well no one can become lost
if you're trying to drive around between
Baghdad Avenue Baghdad I mean sorry
between Saddam Hussein Boulevard Saddam
was saying roadway Saddam was saying
Parkway and there are these huge
magnificent pictures of him all around
town and when in a whole school of
Saddam Hussein art in fact and when he
is asked how can you have them do that
he says well they want to do it well how
can I stop them but it he really needs
this to prop Buffett says his famished
ego now a couple of changes since
nineteen ninety nine to one worth noting
one he really did adapt and learn from
the first experience he was actually
quite surprised at the number of his
Arab neighbors who joined the coalition
against him and he has worked
assiduously to mend that bridge
he has through a combination of
financial inducements and terror really
worked at shoring up his relationship
with the what he calls the near abroad
as Arab neighbors as well as Turkey so
he established the free trade zone with
United Arab Emirates he had has affected
a rapprochement with his lifelong rival
Syria increased the trade of both
through the black market trade as well
as legal trade with Jordan who
desperately need that that support
moreover even with Saudi Arabia there
has been a return to the to the fold in
in many ways or at least not returned
fully to the fold but they took the lead
in inviting him back to the United Arab
summit for the first time after the war
in the year 2000 and then in the Beirut
economic summit in March of of 2001 the
Saudi foreign minister publicly embraced
the Iraqi Deputy foreign ministers kind
of the the the prodigal our brother had
returned to the fold it was really
welcomed welcomed back but he's also
courted the international community and
part of the divisive nough Swee are now
seeing playing out is very much a credit
to his sophisticated international
diplomacy he courted quite vigorously
the the far abroad by which he means the
three permanent members of the other
three other permanent members of the
Security Council o UN Security Council
with veto power namely Russia France and
China Russia stands to lose seven to
eight billion
if this award goes badly and part of the
reason they've been about it this has
been owed them for a weapons purchases
going back many years France has major
economic incentives and of course has
been a friend to the Arab world over
over the years on the other hand while
there's been this increased
sophistication
he's also much more vulnerable in terms
of his security situation in a number of
ways he has relied most strongly on
three places his family the tribes
around to create where he was born and
also the inner core of the of the
military his family is in a real state
of disarray his favorite son Uday came
into a disgrace for his role in the
defection of a Saddam's favorite
son-in-law Hussein Kamel who was in
charge of the weapons of mass
destruction program and gave very
embarrassing degrees on the extent to
their program when he defected to Jordan
he did return at his father's pleading
to Iraq and what I characterized as a
assistant suicide Iraqi style when his
father said come back my boy all is
forgiven and he was killed with a by an
assassination squad led by who day
within two days but he came to blame who
day for this who they was really a wild
man and kind of a chip off the old block
in terms of his his violence and he one
of my mottos for this family is the the
family that slays together stays
together
and his his now his successor designated
successor is kousei who is in charge of
the weapons of mass destruction program
as well as the special security
organization and in a very important
move yesterday which I'd call to your
attention
he removed the military commanders and
replaced not removing them but made a
divided Iraq into forest sectors and put
a coup say in charge of Baghdad and and
and and decree and three other loyalists
were including including a chemical Ali
who was responsible for the use of
chemical weapons earlier in terms of the
other three sectors and I find this
quite telling because these are not
military experts but their loyalty as
unquestionable so that says to me that
he is already very gravely concerned
about the degree to which the generals
will follow his his commands now a
couple of items worth noting while he's
very prudent and is by no means a martyr
indeed he's the quintessential survivor
the question has been raised would he go
into permanent exile I believe the
chances of that are between zero and
none I mean this is a man who the only
meaningful life is a life in power
having said that it is vaguely possible
I think this is highly unlikely - he
might accept temporary refuge in Libya
or whatever with some of his inner core
planning to come back but I think he
knows that there's really going to be no
returning and I was very struck in the
Dan Rather interview his comment that to
go into exile would be both humiliation
a loss of honour and indignity to the
Iraqi people and of course terms of the
Iraqi people Iraq as Saddam Saddam is is
Iraq and anyone who even offered him
that would be
immoral so I think the I think this is
most remote what would he do if he were
backed into a corner and one can make a
case he's been backed into a corner for
some time with not just the cause for
disarmament and but the cause for regime
change I think one can predict that it
is quite not just possible but probable
that he would order the use of chemical
and biological weapons against Alliance
forces in the field if he has the
resources to do so would order their use
against Israel and could even set afire
Iraqi oil fields if I can't have them
nobody well but note I said he would
order his generals to do this and here's
where we run into what I think's been an
interesting and clearly quite thoughtful
aspect of US policy namely to split him
off from his senior military first we
had Secretary of Defense Rumsfeld say
his generals have an important role to
play in the reconstruction of Iraq of
course if they get involved with weapons
of mass destruction all bets are off
then about three weeks after that
President Bush himself said that Saddam
Hussein may well order the use of
chemical and biological weapons if he
does so his generals will be well
advised to not obey those orders so I
think there's a very clear strategy or
having said that what at the same time
not really trusting anyone Saddam has
put his inner core who are I believe
planning to go down the tubes with him
they're so intertwined with him in
charge of the weapons of mass
destruction that that they do have so I
think there is a great danger that that
that this will occur
why overall at this time have weapons of
mass destruction been of such central
significance whim it's been estimated
he's lost 93 billion dollars 93 billion
because of the sanctions and I think
there are really three or four reasons
note I said he had been promoted to
world class world leader in 1990 world
class world leaders have world-class
weapons and big boys have big toys and I
think it's inconceivable for him not to
have these just on that basis alone but
secondly they have been significantly
weakened militarily by the first Gulf
crisis I noticed I noted to you his
weakness in terms of the family disarray
well the military was beset by
defections at a number of coup attempts
as well it put them all down but he was
never able to he's never been able to
rely on them in the same way thirdly the
five tribes themselves centered around
to create there have been major coup
attempts out of the leadership of four
of those so all of these places he can
no longer rely upon it's been much much
shaky er since but one of the ways he's
held on to the faltering morale of the
military has been having the courage
major courage major badge of honor in
the Arab world to stand up against the
superior adversary don't forget to say I
am NOT going to have my sovereignty
compromised I will not yield to the
inspectors I will not yield to the
overflights so this has been very
important for him as well well what does
this mean if he's not a martyr and will
do almost anything to survive but we
don't think he'll go into into exile
first place I really he is rather an
optimist with all of this that will
sound strange to you but after all in
1991 he survived and President George
Herbert Walker Bush did not survive the
next election and he is he has a
deep-seated belief in the in the Vietnam
complex that the United States has in
his judgment and
one of his goals is to get past the air
campaign and then have enough American
body bags so as to cause a political
military standoff because of the
protests around the Pentagon and the
White House going back to the Vietnam
era and bring the war to a close and
then get great support from the radical
Arab world for his courage and standing
up to the President of the of the most
powerful nation on earth so I see this
having really no course but but conflict
to be played out having noted that will
his generals defect I noted the pressure
to separate them out from him in 1991
those who to early raise their heads and
lets the and show their enthusiasm for
the overthrow of Saddam were ruthlessly
hunted down along with their families
which were tortured and executed so I I
don't believe we are really going to see
any kind of movement in terms of major
senior defections or certainly in terms
of any sort of uprising against him
until not only as the conflict well
underway but it is clear that he is he
is on the way out but certainly one
thing we can be we can be clear this is
not a man who will go gentle into that
good night but will rage rage rage at
the passing of the light well let me let
me stop there for some some questions
sir similarities or maybe differences
between him and and Hitler and the
Gotterdammerung kind of end that they
brought on Germany and ended in suicide
and so on yeah the question is are there
any psychological similarities between
him and Hitler to whom he's often been
been likened and by implication would he
commit suicide in a flaming bunker at
the end actually I find him
much more similar to Stalin than to
Hitler indeed he admires the Stalin's
way of controlling his society through
terror and through and through fear and
has the same sort of redundant security
organization that that Stalin did in the
same way of inflicting random terror on
people to control them and doesn't
really have the charismatic attractive
leadership that Hitler had I also find
it very unlikely for the same reason I
don't believe he would go into exile
that he would commit suicide because
he's quite concerned with his historical
reputation and his wanting to see
himself and be known in the radical Arab
world histories as the man who carried
on the the flame and and followed in the
path of Nebuchadnezzar and insomnia and
Nasser and now and now him having said
that I do think he's going to do you
know he'll go down fighting
but it's also quite possible in the
Warren of underground bunkers that he
would really seek to take refuge there I
might note that's the visual metaphor
for all of you of his psychology because
it's it's puzzling to many South Africa
this grand grandiose man possibly be
insecure and of course grandiosity
always sits on a sea of insecurity after
in 1991 the German architects would
helped him construct his underground
bunkers made their drawings clear and I
think it's a marvelous image though that
bunker for his psychology here
underneath here was his grand palace
with inlaid woods marble floors the
finest marble gold accoutrements in the
bathroom facilities Persian carpets
under it this huge underground bunker
with reinforced concrete and steel
enough food to last for a year and a
half
weapons communications equipment to run
the campaign from underground even a
helicopter with a disguised escape hatch
this is his psychology a grandiose
facade sitting underneath a siege state
ready to strike out ready to be betrayed
and ready ready to ready to
counter-attack other questions sir would
it be inconsistent for a secular leader
such as himself to have made ties with
al-qaeda oh that's that's a very
interesting question would it be
inconsistent for a secular leader to
have made ties with al-qaeda I've been
very struck by the attempts to tie
Saddam to al-qaeda and by implication to
9/11 I think the last audiotape by Osama
bin Laden really demonstrates quite
clearly just how much distance there was
between the two of them and again in
fact I I've been very struck after a
long period out of the limelight been
lot there was there was a resurgence of
al-qaeda terrorism in the mid fall after
our attention shifted to Saddam Hussein
and the first audiotape came out then
the most recent audiotape was really
with war being imminent and in effect it
was very disrespectful of Saddam called
the Iraqis heretics infidels hypocrites
and tried to reframe the conflict is not
being against secular Iraq but against
the against Muslims and I sama bin Laden
I am the authentic leader of radical
Islam so I saw this as a kind of a
sibling rivalry of there's only room for
one at the top and and until the
attention shifted to Saddam the number
one enemy at that point was was Osama
bin Laden now I do think one other point
is worth noting and that has to do with
Saddam really working however the
Islamic turf in the last several years
he's kind of rias llama sized secular
Arak built this very large mosque
reported to be either the second largest
or largest in the world of Islam the
mother of all battles mosque which has
parapets shaped like Kalashnikov missile
a Kalashnikov sand Scud missiles and has
a Koran the calligraphy for which was
reportedly done in blood that Saddam
himself contributed over the last
several years he's increased the bonus
for the families of Palestinian
terrorists from 10,000 to 25,000 dollars
so he's really worked to enshrine
himself as pushing the cause the causes
of the of the of the Arab world in many
ways and to and in many ways that says
helped bring him back into the fold of
the of the Arab nations he praised
ostentatiously five times a day but this
man is certainly by no means a devout
Muslim and I see this as very much a
part of a clear strategy on his part now
reportedly about the one never knows
with a Saddam this was his own blood
given over a several years in order to
get give this significance other
questions yes question with all due
respect as an American of Palestinian
descent I take exception to your
characters characterization that all
Palestinians are supportive of Saddam I
have family in the West Bank and that's
not the case there are those
Palestinians I didn't mean to do that at
all but there are Palestinians to
support Saddam because they are so
oppressed by the Israeli regime that
they have no one to reach out to and
when your homes been bulldozed and your
children killed if it doesn't matter if
the devil is offering you twenty five
thousand you're gonna take it my
question is this given the profile
you've given us tonight of Saddam and we
all know that there are many brutal
dictators in the world in the world we
today unfortunately do you in fact
believe that this war is a just warn
that he is an imminent threat well
that's that's that's a question that
many have have raised let me speak to
your first point - I certainly don't
mean to imply by any means all
Palestinians support Saddam the fact
that there's this up swelling of support
at the time of the first Gulf crisis for
him said to him at long last I am now a
heroic figure to the to the radical Arab
world is the is conflict imminent with
the United States would he give weapons
to terrorists is another another
question my answer to both of those is
no having said that this is an extremely
dangerous man having just done a major
profile of Kim jong-il however I see him
as certainly being extremely dangerous
in in his in his own right and I think
there is I am quite persuaded that the
strength of his ambition to be a
hegemonic power in the Gulf is is is is
extremely powerful and he's not by any
means going we haven't yet mastered
personality transplants in medicine and
that he would by no means be willing to
disarm and say I'm sorry I've seen the
light and so forth and so on and he's
retreated many times in the past only to
come back stronger than ever so I think
these characterizations of the danger he
possesses to the region are absolutely
apt as to the when of the decision that
and and the how that's really quite
important I think it's very unfortunate
this is mainly and I guess we'll be
hearing about this at a mainly under US
with Great Britain and in Australia in
Spain about us mainly under US
leadership the more Saddam is able to
play this as the United States against
our Saddam against the United States
against George Bush
Moretz points for him and the more it
stirs up anti-american feelings in the
Middle East the more it is as was the
case in 1991 a major international
coalition and especially under UN
auspices had that been able to be
achieved that's a major constraint for
him because he wants to be seen as a as
a respected world leader so my major
concern really is the aftermath of this
and the amount of negativity in the Arab
world in particular towards the role of
the United States at the back sir the
personal need for stature in the world
and so on is it possible that could be
achieved through a number of different
means
you mentioned certain overtures that he
was making to try to become accepted
after the first Gulf War is it were
there any opportunities in which such as
might have been the case with Milosevic
for example there were ways in which
some degree of integration of Iraq into
the international system and acceptance
of him eeep however repressive in some
ways he may have been domestically might
have waged this desire for this for
grandiose grandiose stature and so on or
does it have would it does it seem that
it had to take the form of of increasing
his command oh well I I don't see that
there was a Oh quite the question was
worth given his deed for international
stature were there ways other where
their opportunities missed along the
along the way to welcome into him into
the community of nations just to
paraphrase and I don't really see that
because it was international stature in
in part but more importantly to be seen
as a hero of the radical Arab world and
to be leading that radical Arab world
against the West and and it so it's from
that point of view I I don't release
see that there were opportunities missed
one wishes however that that what we
will be hearing about tonight had been
worked out with more international
consensus in terms of the the immediate
danger that he presented so that it was
not going alone on the part of the
United States you know Tom survived a
serious illness I think about with spine
cancer and that perhaps conferred some
kind of feeling on his part of
immortality I saw a TV show where a
Cuban doctor supposedly operated on him
and removed a huge tumor on his spine
have you heard anything about that I
have not heard that and I follow a later
illness rather carefully have not I'm
not aware of that which isn't to say
didn't occur but it's so it's so often
hard to separate out truth from fiction
in this room yes considering that this
is there are a lot of people involved in
this George Bush being one of them and
the world now making a lot of the world
may think George Bush is a danger to the
world as big as Saddam and then there
are other parts people in the Middle
East who consider I'll consider Ariel
Sharon a much bigger threat than a
Saddam I'd like to know if you could
give us a comment I'm sure you have
looked at the profile of both Sharon and
Bush and I wondered if you'd comment on
their profiles given that they're all
part of this equation your certainty is
unwarranted for in fact I have I can
find my attention to two leaders
overseas and I've also not done a
profile of a of sharona and the
questions you raised are certainly
important ones and one can't consider in
any international conflict the dynamic
without looking at that dynamic between
leaders but I'm not being comparative
here other questions you
of this knowledge before the dictator
ends up in this position of power
torturing people wreaking havoc that's a
very interesting question are there any
implications of these kinds of
understandings before a dictator rises
to the kind of place that that the
Saddam has well with the wisdom of
hindsight one might question for the
expediency of the moment back at the
time of the iran-iraq struggle our
concern over Iran leading us in fact to
provide support to to Iraq at that time
that's kind of a reality of
international politics which which many
somewhat regret just as just as in many
ways the support during the conflict
with the Soviet Union in Afghanistan
that we gave to Osama bin Laden ended up
really being a stepping stone to his
leadership but this has happened before
and will happen again but it does
emphasize as we are assisting leaders
early in their rise to power who may
temporarily be of some assistance to
u.s. goals we ought to be very sure that
whom we are assisting don't already have
the clearly the clear markers and
indicators of a future danger sir
information do you get to question is
about the methodology which indeed is
spelled out in some length in this book
as is the methodology of half a dozen
other colleagues who have kind of
considered the kind of leading a
political uh profilers isn't so far
different than the type of methodology I
would employ in doing a clinical study
of an individual with a number of major
differences however the first place
collecting all of the biographic
material I can find including authorized
biographies and approved biographies and
oh you know the kind of campaign
biographies and one might ask why on
earth would you want even bother looking
at such books well that's a the kind of
the way the person would like to be seen
and what is omitted in contrast to the
real biography are the areas of
sensitivity that the that the person has
secondly went over some twelve years
worth of speeches with Saddam which are
extremely grandiose the speech after his
successful invasion of of Kuwait was
quite remarkable he was almost talking
about this as an act of religious
consummation designating him as a
messiah
thirdly we look very closely at the
relationship between him and his
leadership circles and in Saddam's case
it really emphasizes how this person can
go because of the distorted feedback
from his followers for good or good
reasons fourthly we look at key patterns
over lifetimes quite II it's often the
case that in them in the midst of a
crisis our government will get so
preoccupied with the current
intelligence so called it forgets the
patterns but when you have patterns over
a lifetime of how does this person react
in crises what are the issues that have
driven him in the past how does he
respond and so forth it's it's really
important to be able to identify those
other things being equal like the
weather that's the way he will behave
again at the time of the initial Gulf
crisis I had indicated this man is a
survivor has reversed himself on a
number of occasions and could reverse
himself again if double contingency if a
he could preserve face and be he could
guarantee could preserve his power base
but in the immediacy of the situation
where he had really painted himself in a
corner which was then compounded by the
government at Thea at the time there's
no way of changing face and he had every
reason to believe
that the military response would not
stop at the borders of of Kuwait I also
interview as many people as I can find
of dealt with the person so I had the
opportunity of having major many hours
long debriefings of both a former
diplomats and former business executives
who dealt personally with Saddam by the
time one has done that I begin to get
the feeling
delusional it may be that I I know him
as well as as anyone in my office oh
really yes at the back there yes I have
done a profile of Arafat his
decision-making structure is like
internally in his head the way he goes
about making decisions
well Arafat's a very complicated
individual and one way of thinking of
Arafat has to do with see you know the
importance throughout his career of
being seen as the leader of the unified
Palestinian resistance which has often
kept him from making moves to that when
things were beginning to come to a place
where there could be some movement
towards peace when the the rejectionist
front was balking at any moved towards
moderation and rather than make a move
to separate himself from them and the
need to hold the movement together it
gave them an effective veto until his
plane crashed in the Libyan desert and
it was initially feared he was killed it
was found the next day he was seen
wandering days than his pilot was was
indeed dead and and this gave him even a
grander reputation for survival amongst
his people but six weeks later after
this he was rushed to kinga Hussein
Hospital in Amman Jordan for emergency
brain surgery
to remove two blood clots to the brain
from that trauma to the brain II had
suffered in the accident it was after
that that he entered the account the the
Oslo Accords I believe there is a strong
part of his psychology which wants to go
down in history as the far as the
founding father of the Palestinian
nation and that emphasized to him the
shortness of his mortality and of the
need to do something before he shuffled
off this mortal coil to accomplish that
goal but under pressure he often reverts
to his kind of default position of of
being the leader of his people against
them rather and has had difficulties
being a leader for them which has been
often a problem for many revolution area
for many revolutionary leaders sir one
gets this odd stereoscopy of the
attitude of Iraqis towards Saddam part
of it is explained by your these or what
you see internally is explained by the
sort of terrorism and all that but the
the extent of the antipathy towards
surround by by typically among Iraqis
who are not in the country how would you
how would you expect the reaction to be
among Iraqis the sort of gut-level
reaction to what's being proposed now
well we have to distinguish here between
what we know what we might hope for and
what we fear because the as I understand
it we have really quite poor
understanding of what the man in the
street really feels people are really
terrified of betraying anything other
than adulation for this man I've talked
to a number of journalists who have been
in the area and who indicate that it's
their impression and some of these
people have on the one hand let it be
known some of their discomfort and fear
of Saddam but are equally strong in
their negative feelings about the United
States
I mean this notion that we will walk in
and our soldiers will be garlanded with
roses I think is is a sadly mistaken
probably but during the first Gulf
conflict there were waves of defections
from the military and there's certainly
as reason to believe at lower levels of
the government and of the military that
this will happen again but we really
don't know you hear something I mean it
varies but you hear some very very
enthusiastic voices for what what Bush
is proposing understood and enough and
that's quite correct and and many of
those who who left to find a new life
are very eager to see him overthrown how
widespread that feeling is within Iraq
we can conjecture but I just mainly
saying we ought not just take our own
wishes and make that make that reality
no yes yes I would say so question was
if we go to war will be short and quick
or will be long and drawn-out I think
there's every reason to think that the
initial part of the conflict will be
rather hopefully rather short the
aftermath though I am very concerned
about and and the degree to which the
really three disparate parts of Iraq the
Shiite South the Sunni Center in the
Kurdish north will hold together
afterwards and what that means could be
a very problematic indeed yes bringing
democracy to Iraq which is the Bush
Doctrine now I hear well democracy is
not a strong suit in the in in the in
the in the Middle East to be sure and
there is a great
respect for strength and I I think it's
a lovely concept but I see that as very
very far off indeed and worried about
agar in cohesion in the in the in the
short term sir the important question
and this is a personality question and
what containment have worked with Saddam
I mean nobody seriously believes that he
voluntarily disarmed or they voluntarily
stepped down but the anti-war argument
is that there's other options the option
is containment that he would that he
would rationally calculate that if he
ever crossed his borders again
militarily that would be the end and the
world would be united against him would
he be capable of seeing that well I'm
not so sure we can say that containment
worked it's true that some in a conflict
given the stores of anthrax botulinum at
such a which were confirmed by Hussein
Kamel when it came out and they and the
destruction that did occur and what
hasn't been accounted for what has been
developed during this period of time we
have every reason to be quite fearful if
I don't see this as a as a confine above
and it's it's yes it's worked in a
narrow sense we haven't had a war since
as he's been rebuilding but it sure
hasn't seen him change his spots in any
way for from from my point of view yes
when was he born appears to be a lot
older than what I've read he seems to be
a lot older than his manner is
reminds me of my grandfather who had had
a stroke when he was 80 and the way he
sits he has a good body but his face
doesn't look quite right I I know of
evident no evidence that he's had a has
a stroke he sets he he's now 19
I guess 66 I think that's right
but he's quite really quite vigorous and
there are many phases to a Sadam and
there's the genial father and the
sportsman and the military and I was
very struck in the rather interview he
was in his statesman robes hello so it
was quite extraordinary but he he could
be around if he didn't if he does
survive this for many many years and
sees himself as being around immortally
through his through his sons to be sure
two more questions all right
any others yes I'm sorry I didn't hear
you will turn out to be there third
world war well the war with Iraq turn
out to be the third world war no III
don't I don't have feel that at all
having said that that it will have major
diplomatic and policy consequences for
years to come seems very clear and we've
had these questions here one last
question yes about Clinton is well could
you spend a few minutes on telling us
what what you had to say about him yes I
should note quickly that the reason this
book goes back many years in its history
actually goes back seven years and we
carefully delayed the publication to
coincide with current events you see but
the reason for choosing Clinton it was
during Clinton's presidency when this
project started and we wanted to
contrast what personality assessments
can accomplish when you have an
autocratic dictator with what with how
you address the complexity of assessing
a leader in a democratic nation with the
kinds of constraints upon him that that
Clinton had and there is a major
portrait of Clinton in the book by a
colleague and friend Stan wrench on who
did a major psycho biography of Clinton
from which this was drunk the book was
called high hopes and in it he stresses
issue
use of Clinton's own background how they
shaped him how they shaped his his
ambitions in both the the balance
between some was remarkable strengths as
a politician and some of the flaws it's
interesting the the profile was written
well before some of the unfortunate
personal events which which which led to
such major wounds to the Clinton
presidency and I was very struck by the
emphases in the profile that dr. Wrenn
Sean did which emphasized the issue of
of character integrity and of end of
ambition and of the balance between
personal and other concern and drew a
portrait which in some ways was rather
prescient of some of the events which
ultimately came to pass well I thank you
very much for your attention and I and I
wish you a Gerald post is director of
the political psychology program at
George Washington University and author
of the psychological assessment of
political leaders it's published by
University of Michigan press
visit press dot u mich dot edu for more
information